[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i have been looking forward to
talking with darren heightner
like all weekend you need to check him
out on twitter at darren heightener
he's an attorney an arbitrator
he's got a lot of stuff going with
sports entertainment intellectual
property
but he's on here today because
he knows as much about nil
which is it's almost a year now name
image and likeness as anyone out there
and arguably
one of the five best players in college
football
is a free agent right now his name is
jordan addison
he's a wide receiver from pitt who
absolutely tore up the acc last year
i mean the guy won the blitnikov so we
just watched the nfl draft thursday
night we saw drake london and jamison
williams and the two ohio state guys and
johan dotson
none of them won the blitnikov
jordan addison from pitt won the
blitnikov
and he is to my knowledge
like the first college football free
agent like this
that is
well we'll find out more from there
we'll find out a lot more from darren
darren really appreciate the time man i
got a million questions for you because
it feels like college football is
totally changing before our eyes
it is and this is a byproduct not only
of nil rights which were established as
of july 1 2021 but importantly the
creation and existence of the transfer
portal you mentioned that jordan addison
is really our first premier free agent
and again even if nil was not in the
picture that could still be true just by
virtue of the existence of the transfer
portal and i think a lot of people
are getting ahead of themselves and i
know that a lot of people especially on
social media are speculating this must
be about nil i saw something yesterday
someone with about a thousand followers
and maybe a thousand retweets
saying that he was offered three million
dollars to go to usc there is absolutely
no veracity to that statement look at
jordan here's an individual as you
mentioned
the volitnikov award winner
he lost his first round quarterback he
lost his coordinator he lost his wide
receiver coach
so can we blame him for just putting his
name into the transfer portal and
looking at what the opportunities may be
out there remember the transfer portal
opens and closes he had to put his name
in just now before the portal closed
that's the big reason why he finds his
his name in there currently all right so
darren are you are you repping him i
guess how do you know how do you know
what he has or hasn't got from usc
unless uh are you i and by the way just
so people know
they are allowed to have agents now they
i mean you know they are allowed to have
people repping them
and i are you repping him i guess how
otherwise how would you know what he has
or hasn't been offered
i am not currently representing him much
like you i have some very strong sources
people who are very close to him and
unlike many of the individuals who are
out there speculating on social media
hearing from those individuals i'm told
that all these assumptions that are
being made are very false thus far um i
did work with kenny pickett on his
intellectual property when he was in
college
i know people surrounding this specific
situation and uh while i'm not
representing him and i'm not an agent
i'm a lawyer who works closely with
agents and with players um i do have
some pretty good information all right
so darren let's just forget how much usc
supposedly offered him because i've seen
the three million dollars in a house in
california and all that stuff
but let's let's get to the crux of this
they could right i mean he's in the
transfer portal
name image and likeness there's these
collectives now which i want you to
explain
but
it's basically legal now
correct me if i'm wrong
for
certain collectives from schools like
tennessee or texas a m or whoever to say
hey jordan
you know there's there's a good chance
you'll have a million dollars or two
million dollars of name image and
likeness money if you come play college
football here
it's a complicated question uh from a
legal standpoint there are roughly 25
states that currently have nil laws in
place california being one of them and
by and large these laws actually
prohibit the offering of money to
players before they're enrolled and then
if you separate the law
from the rules i know the ncaa has not
really done anything
since july 1 2021 to enforce its nil
regulations but
in its bare bones rules one of those and
i think the most important to the ncaa
is that there can't be compensation
offered to a player contingent on the
athlete enrolling at a specific
university which is exactly what you
would have here if in fact a collective
and a collective being a third party
not part of the university but with a
specific mission to support the
university and the athletes at that
university so if you have a collective
making an offer like this
it could put the university itself
in a pickle with the ncaa but more
importantly if the player actually
engages in these types of conversations
before being enrolled
the athlete is putting unnecessary risk
on himself because if the nca decides
one day to wake up and take action to
enforce its rules i think that's where
it's going to look god forbid someone
like jordan the balitnikov winner ends
up becoming ineligible for this upcoming
season so i think if we're looking
objectively it just doesn't make sense
for someone like that to take that sort
of unnecessary risk
well so first of all
the ncaa hasn't done anything it doesn't
seem like they're going to do anything
they're not they're not into it secondly
i guess you know i i saw some contract
details of the california quarterback
who's going to tennessee and they don't
say he has to go to tennessee but all of
his appearances have to be in knoxville
tennessee right i mean there's ways to
get around although that would be
hilarious if he signs with alabama and
just drives up to knoxville for all of
his appearances for the 8 million but i
i know darren you're a lawyer i know
you're telling me the letter of the law
but i guess you'd have to tell me like
if i'm will anderson from alabama or if
i'm bryce young or cj show if i'm any of
these guys
why do i not go in the transfer portal
and see what's out there see what
collectives might be willing to offer me
well i think that
it doesn't make sense for every player
why would a bryce young want to create
that sort of controversy and turmoil
potentially within the locker room
especially someone like that who is a
clear leader probably projected to be
the number one overall pick next year
and is already earning seven figures in
nia so it certainly doesn't make sense
in every sort of circumstance talking
about your specific example of the
quarterback from california
who uh committed to tennessee and there
were rumors about a big offer i think
upwards of eight million dollars to him
i want to hear something interesting
after that uh offer was accepted and the
player committed the state of tennessee
actually amended its nil law so that
there's no longer a prohibition
on causing compensation to athletes
by the by the universities and and by
the athletic department so we're
starting to see states actually scale
back on their regulations that they put
in place before
the ncaa adopted its own policy july 1
2021. i mean realize before july 1 of
last year the ncaa didn't allow for any
of this which is why you saw so many
states
jump to pass this type of legislation
now that the ncaa's involved and as you
mentioned it's very bare bones the ncaa
has not acted in any way you see this
sort of scaling back on a state-by-state
basis because of what's occurring and
that's what i think a lot of people are
concerned about
scaling back the ncaa doing nothing and
creating the quote-unquote wild wild
west yeah i mean darren i you know i
i've talked to enough people now
what some of these transfers are getting
like group of five transfers to go to
power fives what they're supposedly
getting at least i mean they're
basically free agents i don't blame them
uh they're getting not only opportunity
at the bigger schools but they're
getting money and
i mean more power to them i guess the
one question i have about the
collectives
so the collective is these university
boosters
that the school boosters they they pull
together a lot of their money so let's
just say um you know jordan edison is
getting a million dollars to go to usc
we're just a hypothetical example okay
what i don't understand is
how do they then determine
what he does for that million dollars
like if if every guy if there's 10
different business owners in california
that are usc fans they all give a
hundred grand towards jordan addison's
million bucks
how do they know like what he ends up
doing for the money i feel like i'd be
like listen i want them at my car
dealership right i want him to sign
autographs or i want him to post a tweet
about my company
it's all codified in contracts so
when players are receiving these
substantial sums of money from
collectives or from really any third
party even brands
they all have to be these terms have to
be written in a contract and the
contracts must be turned into this to
those universities um every university
that i'm aware of has a specific
platform that they use in order to take
in these contracts some actually review
them some just document them um but one
of the again bare bones regulations of
the ncaa and there are really only three
of them is that there must be what's
called quid pro quo in every sort of
transaction so the athlete must be doing
something
in exchange for that sum of money a lot
of people would argue
it's not real this isn't really nil if
an athlete is posting a few times on
social media in exchange for a million
dollars
is the other side of the table actually
getting a true benefit of the bargain
but the ncaa doesn't provide specifics
there as long as there is quid pro quo
that's what satisfies the rule
is there a rule that you would implement
there and is there is there a way that
we can make this better or do you think
it's good the way it is it it just it
kind of feels like a mess right now to
be honest with you man
it does but to be honest i know this is
going to rub a lot of people the wrong
way
i'm actually a proponent of pulling back
on the regulations and restrictions i
like the idea of creating as close to a
free market economy as possible similar
to professional athletes there are
absolutely no restrictions on your
favorite professional athlete doing
deals outside of the salaries that they
receive and we haven't even touched on
that college athletes aren't earning a
salary for the labor that they're
providing but
i love it as an athlete advocate i think
it's fantastic that athletes now have
this opportunity to make money off the
field off the court etc and if someone
is willing to pay money to an athlete
why not take it um now again in the
current system and structure that we
have you have to abide by the ncaa rules
or else risk the potential of being
deemed ineligible and obviously abide by
the state laws but we also haven't seen
any enforcement there thus far i just
i'm scared for the moment when that
actually occurs
darren really appreciate the time
certainly check him out on social media
at darren heightener we posted a picture
at dp show of darren when he was like 18
maybe 19 sophomore year of college it
looks like no facial hair which is
amazing thank you darren
thanks for having me
there he is darren heightener yes paulie
that's funny that picture is he looks
like he's 12.